[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
it's Wednesday and we're playing Friday
the 13th Jake on Wednesday the 24th
that's right uh yeah if you uh caught
wind earlier this morning we had some
technical problems due to this guy
apologies but rub and run we're doing it
we're having a great time
cut to gameplay let's do this ah we have
so far already going to should we we
have yeah people in the office here so
we have a Joey video producer Nick
margarita gameplay John Luke video
producer and chassis but so you can get
one more person here Peter who is
reviewing the game where Rizzoli was
gonna be or was with me this morning
that we had hit little hiccup however um
he is too busy working on he's playing
three games and reviewing them all yeah
he seems pretty busy so he's busy he
can't do it that's no problem uh try to
get in one more time and then we'll just
get rollin there are people playing this
game we did a little test so that's
happening and let me know if we sound
too loud or the if the gameplay audio is
too low whatever I can adjust that as we
go
absolutely uh Jake you and I played some
last night we were in the office pretty
late we did it has its moments but that
are a lot of fun uh but it also has its
moments where it's really boring
yeah and boring can be included into the
network problems we were having
yesterday we were we spend almost half
the same amount of time just trying to
get into a game so hopefully you know we
like to think over a week maybe a little
have these things ironed out but we'll
see which is why we have a review in
progress that's currently the written
portion is live on our site gangster
calm and we'll have a video review in
progress progress tomorrow well we try
Peter one more time he's out alright
sorry Peter yeah just get to it people
want to see
the people it's way lower can't hear
game-pod you there's not a whole lot
going on right now when the game
actually starts fit still - I'll crank
it up a little bit yeah a little bit
more um outlaw asked about a
single-player mode apparently they might
have won and we lost all of what I
closed the party that's what I did
oh no Rob I thought closed the party
meant like I dunno more people can join
that's really dumb I apologize guys so
real quick sorry everyone
I'm always ruining things
yep the audio is - I know I ended the
party off to a great start what's a good
party pooper Rob the party pooper i'm
mr. meeseeks look at me can't do I can't
do says Eric Tay
he's so happy with me alright we're all
here cool what's why get to it did did
pee Brown SF join he looked like I think
he's hurt he was crying and just ran
away like he wasn't even on Steam okay
but we had a pretty good uh time last
night uh uh I for the first time as a
counselor was able to flee and and win
yeah I let you guys though oh yeah you
were Jason that's why due to experience
a win so yeah you loved that we were at
the car we got the car running and he
comes up cuz Nick margarita kept failing
on the battery so I heard it and uh yeah
he heard it and showed up and I got a
flare in your face you did right in the
dome and he just stiffs up and there's
Nick in the chat is as I left him
because there's two person car and
they're three uh there were three of
them sorry there were three of us okay
so Brady beast wants us to make the
facecam bigger I'm sorry I told Tay it
should be a little bit smaller but it's
I don't know how to make it bigger from
here
yeah I don't know and we normally have
another profile Tay might come in later
and help us out here so I really want to
see us anyways so if you're not familiar
with the game you get to pick so I've
been I've been rocking Chad because kind
of look like I'm you know so you here I
have some points here so you know as you
play the game you get CP here and then
you can roll it and get perks Kevin Tran
asks there's only one map at launch
correct no they're actually three
however I have a hard time telling the
difference between them so yeah yeah
totally start the game we're waiting for
waiting though yeah we're waiting for
people so you play a character look at
this nice pose here if I get to level 13
I get any cheers to see where I can be
yeah hopefully some you know you can
only imagine but my god Jake level 91 oh
yeah
kidding me oh my it now just say thing
about like for I don't know uh Billa
bang I don't know who that is
I also got a mic here hey Billa bang
maybe you can hear us
can we hear him oh yeah we should be
able to right if they have mics
undecided that's a killer name that is
good
let's ready up so you can honestly pick
Jason and there's different I'll
actually want to see you know the how
many movies are there first a lot
there's like a dozen I'm working on at
Easter Egg gang and just looking through
the movies there's there's one that was
supposed to be the final part but then
there was they made like six after that
so twelve well John Luke is uh cheating
watching the stream okay and playing he
better for Jason he'd better now look
undecided said hello he did he heard me
um really launched for consoles I don't
know will it I don't think so I mean
they should probably get this version
yeah yeah done cuz I I mean yeah again
oh my god that's my character sure that
is me getting a little head squeeze yeah
a little bit of a facelift yeah look uh
maybe I got massage that's a total
massage so yeah maybe this is like
prequel Jason there with the you know
just a little bag on his head
Friday the thirteenth seems kind of
boring well you can watch the stream
decide for yourself it definitely has
moments that are boring but it also has
moments that are a lot of fun and hence
I this game requires a mic like I yeah
yeah the only way this is just the
seconds Haven ah good we're recording
this hey guys this happens every time
coming so let's say we all right that's
not who I picked Kevin trans out on ps4
next have to escape yeah you're right
this isn't who you pick maybe I didn't
okay it so yeah so you have stamina
there by on my bottom right what's
interesting about the stamina too is
that it drains while you're not what
you're sprinting just while you're
running to right you have to walk and I
don't think it moves anything you have
to hold still for it too nope
I do that all the time this is the thing
is like you really have to like be in a
very specific spot for any kind of
interactions yeah like fortifying is
always is always it's always a shame
alright geez it's always a pain right
back oh I've done bed nope yeah if you
have any questions in the YouTube or
twitch chat do put them in there and
Jake will have the room oh car battery
so this is uh this is kiotas your bat
though so yeah ideally you'd want to be
with another counselor here and they can
protect you while I make the run so
let's see here yeah I don't have a map
but the car is actually really close the
blue one can hold four people right in
the yellow - oh is that right I think
that's what the guy was saying last
night right when you guys drove off
without Nick and then I
that makes sense yeah I forget which
yeah okay so blue cars - I think blue
car is for okay good now and I know also
Jason can hear you better when you are
off the path okay so I think you're good
now but when you start walking through
the woods anything yeah you gotta tell
when you hit bushes and stuff that'll
make up pretty significant I wouldn't go
to the car though right now uh can I
just try this drop this oh [ __ ]
scoot good get to your teammates and
maybe distract Jason with them teammates
I got a battery I'm coming to you and
there's someone else following me I
think it's Jason hey how are you hmm so
what's coming
sorry about the window yeah set it up uh
Joey you look really calm no not there
does someone see that who's reported to
that phone or something like that I have
a battery and uh we got to go I need to
repair the cell phone he's trying to
repair the telephone no lmao he did not
dead yet not dead yet
what is the crunching sound I hear it
might be the keys from Rob's keyboard
crunching yeah I don't know what that is
I take it the red mark on the map is
Jason yeah
which is which is weird because uh I
don't know why but it says rose and
fight Rob I don't know I got nothing to
fight way everybody and with a hit him
with a car battery and also Jason
doesn't die remember move your ass
go oh sure now don't wrap yourself in
here that face does it have
single-player no it does not at the
moment but I guess they were considering
adding some oh you're risking it I just
want to put it in there and leave did I
do it note no always come back out
Oh God move you're [ __ ] my French
Jason leave us alone please we're just
trying to fix the car and leave you're
gonna lock yourself out no mr. Jason
wants you dead I got nowhere stamina uh
so I can free yes nice there we go later
player drop the battery maybe that'll
give you a little bit more mobility I
think so I feel like I'm a little more
more mobile
that'll slow him down definitely I would
get to your teammates oh my god I have
no more stamina he's just gonna Oh God
that stamina is hard to manage
he warped
brother you turn around no this is not
going well I need stamina I don't think
you'd get another action oh you know
here break free so I get I got stamina
boost there which is nice
sure talking where are we gonna go it's
not gonna go well dude
[Music]
ah uh any other counselors in the camp
he's just still there go in that
building God Jason is so cool if I was
Jason I would go for someone else but
you know that's just me
yeah I'm a teacher I'm I don't it how
many kids Hey look at Jason another
counselor hey guys guys over here you
have that mr. button boom what's he
trying to do I don't know
so are you broken free everything you
know she might have a perk that allows
her to get away easy or something like
that you should you should really give
up on you it's you think you can't she
just go will she'll drown if she goes in
middle of Lake hey the doors were locked
okay Chad it's you up
it is me Chad we need to uh be any
weapons here you need some help need a
first aid spray ooh yeah guys go to the
door this is gonna hurt I don't want to
do it oh he just got stuck himself
Chad you idiot Chad oh you hear that I'm
not screaming run girl screaming
normally maybe that is whatever gasps
let's go on this metal except what about
the went to the battery do you remember
it's it the batteries in the car by the
way everyone the batteries in the car
and Jason is right behind me find gas
and keys and figure it out good okay
foot behind you look behind you
oh nice oh where you move a low blow
humbug so that was some environmental
damage there yeah yeah if you find like
a fire or like maybe that's what he was
trying to hailing a rail yeah he was
yeah smart well what else is when the
game is bad so yeah we look at oh my God
look at that face
you think he's scared so you get scared
also when you're like in the dark
outside not in the house oh yeah let's
say we does here oh he's dead there goes
another nice position
yeah so I think when you're when you're
when you are more scared you can kind of
see like a vignette on your screen if
you're a counselor closing and he Jason
can find you easier also your HUD gets a
block to when you I'm in that cities
weeks your HUD gets blocked to like your
magic ability things like that yeah
damnit Chad South Park damn it champ
this guy gets around Oh ethical close
the door you send a goose lock it
and now run nope that move I tried that
once in Peter acts in the queue to
window
oh really so but yeah what Jason can do
is he can he can chop the window and
create glass so then if so you if you
climb through you get right yeah we're
back to where we were talking about like
now we have to wait for what see here
well hopefully not 10 minutes in 30
people yeah left but all these people
three people ok 10 minutes left on Luke
the killer I make sense but um yeah we
have to wait like you can't leave and
then start a new game because you'll
lose experience yeah you have to finish
most your experience just by completing
the game you get like 500 which is
enough to get a perk right I don't
really know what the flashlight does she
didn't jump nice moves you still don't
know it on I do keep it somewhat but
anyway yeah I don't know that make them
so I start you take it off you gotta put
it on yeah totally yeah I don't know the
flashlight doesn't me I guess for the
like I would only imagine like I can see
at night pretty well I would imagine
maybe like maybe Jason can see it easier
I don't know if I don't get wanting this
kick home but cool yes I said I love my
Phillip everybody else says what's the
game about like what are the objectives
just hide and seek good questions with a
mule because after I meet this guy will
answer it
nope
i'm keiko no uh-uh so yeah there are I
believe three three ways you can win as
a counselor there is one waiting it out
which is kind of risky because Jason
kind of progressively throughout a match
gets more and more power powered up like
the the timer's different depending on
the game - I think right you can vary
that's one that's probably the least
desirable thing the other one is is
again this game is very team centric
with counselor so like you can you can
start a car and leave in the car
that's by finding the car keys the gas
and matter a battery and there the gas
and the battery have kind of minigames
where you um if I'm trying to install
the battery it's like left and right
time to clicks if I get it wrong I make
a noise and Jason could hear it you
don't want to screw that up and then the
other way is you get the get a fuse into
the radio maybe another part and you
call the police yeah and then it a
quicker timer starts like in the top
left there below the one that's there
and the police come in like I don't know
if it was eight minutes now I'd be like
I feel like two minutes
we're like four minutes they'll come um
you can also there's a radio that if you
interact with when someone dies they
come back as I forget his name but he's
in the movies but he's got a shotgun and
he's like I'm here to kill Jason right
and that I service something and it's
like yeah Jon I think you're right
Jarvis something Jarvis right so and
that will allow someone Orvis that will
allow I think randomly of one or maybe
it's like the last person who died in
game as a counselor will the Platt
player will come back as get another
shot in their shot and literally one
shot yeah Tommy Jarvis yeah Tommy Jarvis
and you can not kill Jason I think it's
just to like help out a counselor you
know to get another another go at
stalling Jason you can also kill Jason
somehow to win that says Kerry I'm not
quite high we haven't done that I don't
know how to do that
Oh see that she got she got scared I'm
seeing a dead body
yeah and then looted everything then who
did everything thanks Chad idiot I hated
your sweater mm-hmm so the batteries in
there you can see it it's tough though
to find like the gas like that's why is
it again it's Oh like chat or nanded
like you have to like talk with people
be like hey I have the gas I have the
battery some says you can kill them with
a gun I don't know about that you with
you I've seen you use the shotgun on a
blank range right and you just done them
yeah I shot Peter square in the face
when we were playing the other day one
of the best ones I think is the flare
you can shoot Jason with a flare and
bass and he'll like fall like be stunned
for a pretty pretty long uh Stephen says
Chad was a tool anyway oh this is Aaron
Sampson decreaser shippin watching as
he's running against the wall I know why
we weren't switching I don't know why
either what's he doing that face oh god
Jason can also pull knives from and
thrown there are few there are like
areas that no one else can reach and he
can like pull knives out of the the
walls install or slow down counselors
someone asked it already went by so I
can see the names 1s is the only map no
there are two other maps however look at
it very similar what's this quality
gameplay right here 10 on 10 what is
going on does Aaron know what he's doing
I don't know so there are some so there
are some characters that have like you
know their stats wait what did he die
that was weird alright next scene
alright so some came back as can you
please answer is there more is there I
have sinned a few times there are more
than there are three maps in total
they're all at night
Bobby's role at night and they're all
kind of around this lake but they're
just different locations as far as like
different types of cabins I don't know
they're they're basically the same
this guy is undecided she's got a
shotgun though what am I doing with my
life those drapes ur ugly wait is that a
yo go back to him whoa wait you can also
find oh she's out Saturday mate
what is she to you just a number
did he just that how is he talking I'm
um you know him oh that's it oh so cute
oh that's nice job ha
voila ah the crystals won't escape
Umberto they go what's he saying rob
easier use your French skills I think
he's saying something about the water
being mucky and not drinkable a lot of
pee oh yeah you know Nick margarita went
to the Amelia the champ when he was
younger
literally yep that's actually true yep
when he says he said on a sunny day if
you row out to the middle you can see
one of the the Jason like dummies that
they use in the bottom of the lake
Jesus so yeah we're regarding that boat
that's Africa that's another way it's
similar to the car you can get I think
its propeller and I don't think it's gas
and you can do just that
hello please send help
Camp Crystal Lake it's Jason
he's back at crabby dad ten-four
he so he showed up late to the party
with the intention of killing Jason
because he brought a shotgun then he
runs to the telephone calls the police
and I need to get the F out of here what
are you doing man yeah [ __ ] help out
what so look at this now so what is the
point of calling the police
if the game is going to end in two
minutes yeah first I don't know so a lot
of people in the chat are saying $40
seems too much for this game $20 seems
like a reasonable price obviously $40 is
that really what it is it's what it is
like yeah I bet I people are like
honestly I would whoa-ohh
teleported um yeah to anyone who's on
the fence like this one over here and
that was really dumb I would wait I
would wait yeah you know this
again would like if you're curious we
have a review in progress right now or
you can you know I know wait wait outta
a couple weeks I mean this thing is
guaranteed you know going it's got a
drop down in price at some point I sure
steam summer sale right there's that
yellow rink I didn't get footage of that
yellow raincoat easter egg wow this
ought to be good so if you were fighting
if you were hiding under a bed or in a
cabinet or any of these like tents and
Jason knows you're there you're it's an
instant insta-kill he can just kill you
with one hit and you can hold your
breath oh it's done it is done I would
run if I was him so she has some bail so
Peter was telling some characters have
like ten at ten as far as a SATs go
stealth and they can just literally
crouch in the woods or like Peter was
doing it like in a corner of the house
and Jason just like could not oh he's
through
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
sleep tight
[Music]
there is be very very quiet
speak English or die baby good Wow
mommy has a reward for you come home
sweetie reminds me my mom I'd love to
see your family photos I'd say there was
a little too much head room in most of
them all right hmm
Gigi everyone I got slammed got slammed
apparently that's what I said that's how
I died well let's give another shot I
got a B Chad yeah I hear the stats you
can see strength conquer one out of ten
and then the more you play so repair
right so this guy could like repair I
think fuses and um I don't know there's
some other things in the map that like
okay so here yeah look it so I got some
some CP to roll so let's see here well
with him you don't buy perks to CP you
just buy like kills and things like that
with with the campers is when you roll
for perks right and I feel like that's
just more valuable right like always
like I don't know it like seems like the
Jason stuff is just cosmetic like
executions right oh I'm not ready yet
yeah I guess I wanted a roll Joe gamer
Joe game legend says who's uploading
review I'm guessing these who's writing
your view Peter Brown wrote through view
tomorrow at some point you'll there will
be there will be a review in progress
video up and then by mid end of next
week we'll have our full review yeah
Joey you can't be my character look at
is everybody everyone no one wants
meeting the other characters decided the
woman the the guy with the jean shorts
and then you I am damn good-looking in
this the sweater vest I can only
remember the first movie I want I wonder
like how many of these like trope or
stereotypical characters are like like
was Chad after guys last time in this
but was like in that was that an actual
character I don't know probably not I
would think but maybe there's a similar
you kind of think maybe just because uh
Tommy Jarvis has shows up in it like
maybe they are I don't know got the
scene
ah
there I am I gotta get out of here
twenty minutes now
when does this come out comes out Friday
Joey is Jason yes it comes out Friday
teamwork guys teamwork so you can also
find a map and a wrench nice nice
protect yourself protection ooh bear
trap ooh put that on the entrance now
don't actually don't accidentally walk
into it like the last guy don't have as
I have I have to but I love how whoever
was that was like step laid it down
stepped in it as Jason was coming in
just like Oh perfect this backfired yeah
it did a lot of wrenches okay so here's
a radio so like oh yeah so everyone
there this is not a prank
we need your help Jason is killing us we
need your help
oh how please someone
hey toxic the shadow Tommy Jarvis has
been called can you let continually call
him I don't think so I think it's just
one in one that's it hmm I thought that
was it okay Jason I smell Jason all
right well I think we've uh and out the
window of course
I think the strategy to do for this is
you all get together at the beginning
all the survivors and you just stick
together trying to like loot every house
yeah I think you're right like yeah like
if you like you can you can like gang up
on Jason and like just slow him down
consistent yeah
and like if if you keep forcing him to
pick between someone then it's it's it's
a little tougher on him I feel like oh
so Chris a says Jake and Rob what song
would you say best represents Jason
Voorhees by title relevance I mean I'm
thinking girls just want to have fun I'm
thinking I'm on a highway to help girl
this is what I have fun probably I could
seem rocking out to that I could I could
- what the hell would surveyed oh that's
right
there stay that's one that's big now we
need some car keys a battery you know a
see easy-peasy maybe a shotgun ass flare
gun a flare gun is I think that's my fit
speech can you get the dev flare gun is
good however it's a one time ooh
we'll come back nope damn it you like
have to be at a certain distance like
it's kind of weird we're all so you'll
you won't be able to lay it down oh
great now I can't whatever
I don't know you can jump through the
window I was trying to do this oh and
not get my leg ripped off by that trap
all right moving on
be like Oh got some up ahead try sprint
home oh who is it
I can seem in there hello fellow
counselor its I try trad Chad it's me
chat
oh it's Erin Han would you like to throw
the ball around a bit and how are you
please hold himself in there don't hit
me idiot
God dang it Erin we must team up okay I
know you can hear me alright that's not
helpful
come on let's move on oh we could set a
distraction with that I know we can
there's one there's one type of speaker
that will let you do that with some here
want a map that alright might as well
nothing what's up let's go hey oh car
battery oh no get that take the car
battery no we need this no thanks he's
taking the machete there Chad would be
in charge you have to take orders for me
alright let's go out the window
follow me
is he following mm-hmm he is following
can we all played the beta right now no
unfortunately the beta ended but this
game comes out Friday very soon
currently Abbas this is full retail so
we're going we're going this way yeah
Aaron stay on the path if you hit any
bushes he'll know damn it
yeah let him know there's a mighty fine
team right um Joe Jackson says so you
should be able to break Jason Jason's
mask off bye bear traps and damage done
if you do this he is slower what takes
more damage I wish I had a map I think
it's this way the car right assuming
don't worry I'll protect Chris eyes got
another question for us this is Jake and
Rob this game looks good for a small
land group what other games of
seek-and-destroy trope would you suggest
for land parties I'm guessing means what
other games like this would you suggest
for land parties maybe or maybe game
modes this game modes would I suggest
uh oh look a car look over here did you
just push you don't you're just ripping
it stripping look it car I'm sorry Aaron
look car battery put in Oh some was
already got the key got you covered
I don't I think that may be the key I
don't I haven't seen any keys but like
I'm assuming see them before they you
can find them in a drawer but it looks
like we can come back for the battery or
can you put it in and we can leave or
just try installing it I guess don't
mess it up don't mess up or else we'll
hear let's do it you doing I never know
what you're doing put it in put the
battery in
what's this firecrackers you're just
dropping everything you got why you
doing with Oh car keys how did you do
that
car keys how did you do this all right
we need gas and then we're out of here
does anyone have any cast oh man you are
really screwing this up everybody's
gonna come I'll be in the house Thomas
your man's know why you aren't playing
as Jason cuz it's random
it's random and you can also have a
preference if you back out to the main
menu you can like prefer to be Jason
which pull you know ideally heighten
your odds Oh imma go you keep at it and
keep distracting uh-uh Stephen is right
Stephen says Vanessa is the worst at
fixing things
no I was a little bit tough for him okay
apparently Aaron that your character is
really bad at fixing things so uh okay
Wade Wilson wants to know which graphics
card is GameSpot using for this stream
are they running something like a gtx
980ti GC X 1080 or 1070 I think this one
has a GTX 1080 I don't think it's a
1080p ID oh we are yet an alienware area
51 oh [ __ ] Aaron's out parents dead no
I'm sorry
Aaron's out of here oh he ran um had to
leave I actually don't I I may I
this isn't my computer so I have to
double-check on the settings I could
crank them up I'm sure no it's early on
forever oh it is yeah hey there's
someone coming I think so what's coming
yes I think I learned how to bear traps
in here - all right we need gas guys oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] headshot headshot headshot he
ran into the
guys we need gas I'm out of stamina this
is not good I don't like this I don't
like to go running past me no oh whoa I
think JC's power that I don't like is
the one where you can warp across the
map I wish instead there's that one
where you go in first person mode and
you can fly super quickly I wish you
just got to use that more like that
lasted long and that's how you got
around instead [ __ ] hey hey John Luke
stay right there
if I made that face in real life would
you not run for the hills
Jonathan be really [ __ ] quiet Johnny
I don't know don't move don't move
hey you're facing looks like mine right
now don't move we need to be quiet I
said don't move
oh it's Jarvis huh yeah hey what
happened your shotgun Jarvis yeah Chris
Hayes says we didn't answer his question
he says what others seek and destroy
game could be good for a land party
party land parties so I guess how about
how about seven Jason's verse one
counselor but I think it means like
other games like I guess you could play
dead by daylight which is some right a
little bit more complex it sounds no no
no like I mean if you're talking like a
set asymmetrical oh no no no no no
something though Danny yeah you're a
little late oh he's for a bear hug well
I'm curious helping me answer your
question this what was that
here's what single player is gonna begin
this yeah well there I am yeah
whoa yes he's got some nice teeth how
white those are I don't want to cut back
to me someone else dead hug to death
Oh what
John Luke got away and this what
happened I don't know how but he did run
jail run for the woods from that day on
if I want to get some where I was or run
an is this digital download or physical
release on ps4 I think it's digital so
that's a weird aspect ratio that is a
weird aspect ratio
that was dangerous
no scary for second
that's Alaskan when this game comes out
it comes out Friday indeed
this frame rates slow down because up to
that looks a little chop here doesn't it
looks chop wait wells in there yeah
health think about it yet some love
what's your plant what's your plan John
Luke yeah if you're not escaping what
are you doing Joseph's gonna get you
joke Joey Voorhees duh-duh-duh yeah me
yeah he does seem like he has diarrhea
no the car battery is already in there
look at his feet what it looks like he's
on it on a treadmill
we're like ice like whoa yeah you know
it actually this is very nightmarish you
know it's like those nightmares you have
where you can't run it's kind of like
that I guess he's going for another car
so it must be yeah must be intention
I've been at that that is the dumbest
run I've ever seen high knees high knees
and you gotta kick your kick your feet
back yeah there is another car we have a
map now No oh there's the other car so
yeah again one of these yeah one of
these cars is a two-seater and ones a
four-seater I think this one's a
two-seater actually I know so because
there's three of us last night and only
two made it out Sir Mix says so
objective is to escape correct now what
if you just survived like what if you
found a great hiding spot so you can do
that and you can't win just by hiding if
you find a good hiding spot the problem
is is that Jason has a lot of abilities
to sense where you are so hiding doesn't
always work that well yeah yeah and like
as the game progresses he gets i wonder
if even his cooldowns are like shortened
as the game continues because by the end
of the game he gives more and more
overpowered but dependent on your
character yeah like there's some
character oh yeah that's it Tomic
escaped again
[Music]
so this is this is one of the biggest
problems with the game is like you
shouldn't have to wait in order to get
your experience from that game you have
to wait 10 12 minutes I mean we aren't a
party though right you don't wanna like
I'm imagine like if if this was a person
who was just hiding in a tent the entire
time
yeah watch that that's all you got to
watch can't watch Jason Jason run is
really done he's the keys well Rob head
and then oh wait there's the keys where
they mister Oh or this happens and then
it's like oh cool I just wasted 10
minutes and I don't even know if I got
that experience sick nope you didn't get
the experience how do you know because
I'm looking at your ball right wait it's
6 I could have and I can't remember why
was that before tight
see the other Jason's here so this thing
is part like I don't know I don't know
enough what the movie is really witty
these aren't the names and they had
different names regardless like oh my
god Wow
it's like look at the cut on the top of
his head look like is a heads about to
fall apart and like you see skin flaps
hanging from under mm-hmm gross so you
got obviously different like weaknesses
and strengths here stalk oh I didn't
realize that yeah
throwing knives oh you're equipped with
throwing knives on this one I like that
look at his traps holy crap we mean his
traps
oh my grass yeah right he is like
shoulder necks
yeah I select that guy no I think I can
right yeah you should be able to how do
I do it though I do it later this just
customisation so yeah you get different
kills here um no I didn't get any CP
though cuz I had 500 already so yeah you
get kids dang yeah that's an issue that
is an issue it's like a real that's
that's practically a deal-breaker in my
book like I should not have to wait for
that long let's go with chat again I
wanna your boy Chad I want to beef his
his stats up can't do anything else so I
can roll right Lions dude yeah Aquanaut
you already have that what's up food so
that's okay so now what that's the other
thing is like you can keep getting the
same perks so you can get dupes
what do you do with dupes really cuz I
was looking at like oh maybe you can
only like if he's got a perk then you
can't give it to someone else but then I
was looking through and yet you can you
give it to anyone and he'll still have
it
well technically oh I see day
well this one's still but the one I had
is still better oh so their stats
slightly vary do you have that special
Jason they made for this game
specifically I don't think so so let's
try to be Jason okay we got some team
here let's get to it all right just get
a fly oh yeah yeah little little stretch
um Emily says please don't roast Jason
for not having a neck I'm sorry I forgot
Jason would not prefer that he would
kill you probably he probably would beep
yeah he probably would when he'd punch
your head off like that yeah
oh that's one of them that happened to
me it's the coolest there's really cool
one word he grabs you and he just
punches your head off like a tetherball
without a rope just like you're gone
into the pushes and that was the thing
is you're working on a video we we
looked at footage from the actual movie
and that happened I which one yeah we
found that so like we think a lot of the
executions are actual ways so Erik
Hernandez says you can sell the perk
that's weaker okay maybe you do that in
progression all right well that's good
that was that's interchangeable there's
no neck areas no neck Jay
it keeps getting air for chastity well
say again
chastity keeps getting an error so I
don't know if she'll be able to join
I'll invite her so I'm not friends with
her [ __ ] I mean that not that I am not
in real life but I forgot forgot if you
cut to maybe John Luke or someone who's
watching to do it and invite her
possibly if you got to camera real quick
I can go desktop and okay front her
actually I don't do that I might lose
audio I changed my mind
sorry we can wait well I just do ready
up well if I ready can one day one of
you guys around can one of you guys
tried invite chasity now quickly thank
you
we can see other people let's take a
look at the other guys here so yeah well
why don't we use her actually 10 out of
10 self yeah I mean hopefully hopefully
we'll be Oh
got it yeah what is what is the radio do
the radio when you're Tommy Jarvis you
do more damage yeah but what are the
odds you're gonna be Tommy Jarvis attack
damage decreased by four
yes exactly yeah my point ditch that
let's try her yeah like I was I saw a
lot of people should we just play oh
here we go we got people coming in you
want more people I'm working on slightly
higher odds of Anderson Lopez wants to
know can you only play with friends if
it's a private match I'm pretty sure
yeah like it won't match make it won't
find people Yeah right yeah then I go to
invite previous players but yeah it's
it's basically only for friends yeah
we just roll army about more people yeah
I say go for it
let's wait for Omega Omega yes make eyes
okay that's for the app microdata ready
yep
captain Dukat ready up go make us ready
up when you get in
just waiting for Maggie
you can ready up to and it'll I mean I
don't wanted to boot him I wanted Scott
in I want to get old boot him well he's
still loading in it looks like Tresckow
maybe give it a little bit
so here's your your meathead strength
there again this guy can repair it's
pretty sneaky - yeah
what's funny there's one guy that's like
yeah is that Captain jean-luc Picard of
the USS Enterprise hmm
the man himself that's right damn
straight he says how do I buy this game
well you can't buy it yet you should be
able to on Friday is that bakla soup the
most delicious soup ever made oh my god
that is the nicest thing anyone's said
to me all [ __ ] date oh you know
it I'm so happy let's play on ready up
yes sir I can already tell this me a
great time there I am again there you
are just getting that getting that
massage full-body massage bottom massage
machine but a massage would you drink me
if I was a soup depends how hot you are
I might put an ice cube in
five four point five four they saying I
don't know I hope they have him nekron
errors forty is already a big ass but
getting constantly kicked makes it less
feeling yeah that is one thing that was
pretty frustrating yesterday is that a
lot of times we would just get kicked to
bottom shows machine
who brought the hot dogs
hey guys
dinner's ready I can't believe you
killed them
God who run like who runs with those
hands like that like she's easily an
alien like let's bet like when she runs
it's an alien
yeah that's how aliens run like I'm
playing like perfect dark right now it's
Elvis remember Elvis don't come in here
oh yeah
fortify bear trap this is what you would
sound like yeah I'm in a cabin everyone
by hear the music Rob you better be
careful yeah good point I think there
was uh there was something to check
behind you too got bear traps God that
would suck yeah that would I think I
need to open it yeah open up that Oh
even though it's just a wrench hey
better than nothing though there are a
lot of wrenches in this camp wrench our
bat right I'd take a bat for sure nice
little home run all right this cabin
sucks
oh and this is a oh wow this room is a
bad room right die this is I know really
this room yeah really
oh that's good a map a map see where our
homies are now request margarita left
the party good
now and I forgot some friends over here
oh it's going to be a no any problems 50
hey guys I'm coming to you how low
spooky but it's not spooky it's Rob cat
Eddie Eddie falls off me prove it take a
peek ok quit messing around let's let's
play serious what do you guys got
anything hopping nothing at all I got a
batch like the whole I checked this
whole area you should bump the music Rob
yeah there's nothing in this house let's
get a party going start that music
should we hit the music and run or
should we okay everybody resin alright
you're taking point soup hey that's me
[Laughter]
someone checked the other half oh wait
now I've been in here this place sucks
get out honestly sorry you're good next
place see this is this is strategy see
this is teamwork is much needed
alright we'll be gone here batar sir I
was saying we have a good teamwork right
now
Oh check those drawers Rob Rob check
those drawers nothing is this game
single-player only no there's no single
player you play online apparently yeah
you're gonna add it they are adding
single player I'm very curious yet what
that'll be like and I would not make
that as a reason to visit map in this
drawer if you guys need one nice Oh guys
I heard something Oh crikey
who health take it that's your same
heater nice
that's all you I took it good little hey
were twins
nice ass ditto come here come here
nice cookie cookies man
hey spooky dang Scott she's got spooky
whipped yeah let's do follow
gtfo up this way you got it ah guys guys
I'm a little scared little scared - Skyy
spooky don't be spooked
this is the graveyard have anything or
is this a waste I think it's got dead
people including us
I need stamina yeah this was this is a
bad look I said she doesn't have the
stamina relevant
let's get though there's an X hey
where'd you go soup okay with you soup
dead spooky stay close I'm a little
spooked
stay on the path follow my ass right
turn right here oh you sound like a camp
counselor oh hey girl all right let's
keep going I can't believe we found
nothing yeah this is not successful
are you the Olsen twins well I think
well I think it's more like a Parent
Trap situation where we're we're at camp
and we find out that were that are the
same and murdered by Jason one of us
will will cut our hair
gasps in here gasps oh nice get it
walkie-talkie in this drawer
Oh open that drawer I'll take this to
the car you guys think I should lose the
bat for a machete machete someone on the
talkie walkie walkie talkie required a
walk I don't know let's get out of here
get away with Kyle crash crash sir
crouch to end tied up Jason's right
there there's nobody for you Nicholas
says this game does look over to the
other why does it seem I mean I don't
think the only time this game is fun is
when it's something like this from
talking with random people friends yeah
this is like the only time I've ever had
fun if you play this by yourself you're
in it again baby and you're not doing
this I don't know this is the this is
this still it honestly this probably
still isn't worth 40 bucks
did you can find other games there like
this you know like come on he's is he
gone he's still there
[ __ ] does he just buy the car I gotta
take a [ __ ]
just slowly walk or helps us find us
attentively soup you're a little far
away I'm he's still over there
he's just lurk as soon jerkin soup
you're always so far away
my hair looks like it's got candy in it
minutes ago this way you should just
take a bite of it right he better a face
your hair okay he's gone I assume the
batteries in the car and maybe the keys
are there too but I don't know that's a
rough assumption I'm not quite sure I
mean why else would he be camping oh
he's he's camping straight up at the car
okay I know that I think he just left
oh he's still there oh my god he's still
there what a wiener it's just [ __ ]
stay in there
should I oh here he goes I don't see him
folks
hide in the bush [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'll
distract him I think he sees me okay
lead him away
hey nice distraction go my twins
[Music]
no I'm not gay but that character kind
of was is that a body around what
happened well I hope they get out of
here I do too
oh I can't hear him now
maybe I don't know I guess not probably
cuz you could feed them information
that's how you have Skype check chat
setup
they're freaking out from a dead body
nursing a car houki going off on his own
spooky that's how everyone dies in
movies you go off on your own
oh not good I can't was it the same game
where we put a battery in I can't
remember what we was even achieve
nothing right we just they found gasps
we found gas but didn't make it to the
car yeah so you have seen people do this
like just crouch in a bush and it works
pretty well
see how bakka super stealing right back
out is that what did he kill someone
just now no he was just doing that to a
bad right um oh no back no or something
says to be honest this looks quite fun
in my opinion at least it stays true to
the movies by looking extremely low
budget and shitty
yeah the movies were very low-budget I
think that's what you're pointing
animations right like even though they
they look bad it like it kind of adds to
the camp enos of this game yeah I like
the you know the cinematic and beginning
right there like yeah it's so dumb like
you know the developers thought that was
pretty funny
Hey but is that like an external like
exactly like that intentional or is that
it's just one of those things like it
you know it hat it does have in the
movies a lot we're just like you know
but we got what $100,000 to make a movie
or something like that
let's just let's let's intentionally
stretch it thin in areas or something I
don't know but again like I don't know
yeah
$40 is pretty steep I don't know if I
like how like yeah I don't know will
this get old my who's to say right like
how many times of this can you deal with
like I don't know like already like I
played eight oh there it is
I'm thinking escape or die oh well
spooky is dead god bless you god bless
oh well he drops in he'll go right
through the car and help yeah all right
it's just soup
[Music]
oh you see him move between the boards
[Music]
[Laughter]
I like this imagine Jason thinking right
now like where would I be if I was a
counselor I know I know what he's doing
well I gotta wait six minutes for this
how we doing on time here 3:10 okay done
about an hour and 10 minutes go up so
yeah he can he can break these windows
now she goes out she'll hurt herself or
lose health Oh what are we doing now
Jason's doing a good job breaking all
these windows yeah yes so he can also
that's a fuse box there for the lights I
think he can he can break that and kill
the lights making them more scared and
easily spotted I believe no there's
health okay Mandy if she's gonna keep
jumping through windows this is true
she's I think Sheila's so she's pretty
calm right I don't know like I feel like
she's Dolphy I don't know she's calm but
she seems alright still she's very
stealthy oh thank you get away
a worker or through the window oh that
killed her huh
all right I mean uh we were doing that
left and right like just flying through
windows all right
that's my good boy Mommy has a reward
for you I never knew come home I don't
know I'm I'm gonna try it attempted
knowing to lure up JC I did I didn't
know it was like a psycho premise yeah
infatuated with his mom or whatever it's
mommy issues mommy issues what do you
think one more I think one more will do
it that would fill the slot pretty
nicely good game everyone hopefully well
yeah hopefully we'll be Jason I mean I
did say yeah my preference people down
on that her composure was pretty high
oh that's what I composure is pretty
high because I remember like not so much
him cuz I feel like I was always the
mouth open I don't have much of a choice
here
which we stick with her the last girl I
can't select it
okay go I'd stick with her yeah okay
hmm well
I can't chant I'm not host am I uh hey
uh who is it Joey Joey Joey and jean-luc
a Joey uh maybe try different map
despite them being really much the same
actually I don't know if he can change
it
the host can oh the host can yeah which
is what women won't
what's women's once well this game cost
$60 nope 40 $40
are they playing this on this is on pc
it is on pc I don't think it's on
anything else pretty sure it's just PC
no the chats been saying uh should be a
xbox one and ps4 come out should we come
out same days really yep can we back
check that I mean yeah look no offense
chat but that's really surprising me
because the beta was only on PC right
yeah platform so h2 here yeah Xbox
I saw Xbox Playstation all right I guess
Oh
Xbox ps1 yeah yeah that's Xone ps4 oh my
god Oh were they like a nag this is
different Matt different Matt pack an
act
we got a full server here pack pack an
ACK man I hope I'm Jason that'd be a fun
way to go out fingers crossed
packing act hey guys it's always this
guy always this guy hey I don't think
that's you cuz I'll think enhance Pierre
damn real is this real life or is it
fantasy mm-hmm caught in a landslide no
we're not doing that
all right map that's good I'll take it
let's lock this lock despite there being
no law fair find more drawers to open
okay let's open drawers I'm in know
another map someone's already put into a
music they got a new buddy ja but ran
out our sorrows with some tunes and
there we go
you guys hear that new Waylon album
mmm-hmm
oh god you scared me you scared me let's
team up I agree
nice oh yeah this is pretty good just
lock all these doors yeah oh this is
shotgun right here man shotgun let me
have that all right you can take it take
the shotgun
should we it's over here on the couch
should we take it and bounce alright
I'll follow you
that's my first game dude okay you can
follow me how do I use the shotgun you
gotta aim down sights the right mouse
button yeah you got it hey Chad Nick
over here - look to your left
hey what's up uh you can't talk I know
but let's go over here actually school
in this cabin up here this cabin might
be some good [ __ ] and they follow me
okay
OS k luck it looks like how I got fixed
that power boxing says this might be
pretty cool with proper player action
yet feel like that is when we have the
most fun is when there's proper player
interaction with nice comment mates
you guys should strategize like who's
gonna shoot first cuz you don't wanna
both shoot him well he just left he said
he was gonna go fix something
oh yeah clothes they I locked that [ __ ]
oh did you hear that I heard a no oh
great this is a good sign isn't it yeah
you look pretty good this looks this
looks like a good sign
he just walked by no it was a woman
trying to get in
that's all two people I thought I
wouldn't open the door and risk it
someone died it sounded like someone
just died oh there he is right there
okay we got to go pet and he just died
[Music]
oh we should I click through the wall
yeah he was
no one's here you give up
you NIC bounced Oh
ah hey how are you yo throwing my piece
fit everywhere that dive is so dumb he
can't get me right here where you gonna
trap
well yet oh [ __ ] you get out of here
well I guess when he smashes the rope
you can I can go back through there or
you can work next to you you think I
don't know
I think he's gonna give up I think you
should give up you should go for Nick
let me tell Matt hey you should totally
go for Nick I got nothing at all a value
oh look there's another guy around the
corner it's John Luke it's John Luke I
hear he tastes great
oh it's Joey Joey look at John Lucas
always were over here
he's over here
[Laughter]
where is he they want you to do a
balcony dive I think we I don't know you
can't you can't do a balcony like break
her neck too cuz that jumped through the
window like hinges are quite a bit oh I
wouldn't go through there idle passion
[ __ ]
he's probably wait
I guess I would hear them so let's go
let's give a shot pop the door open
you're just gonna grab you and kill you
damn it am I getting points is that is
that the grind
yeah just keep opening I don't like this
I don't like this let her into a trap
what happened Oh what the hell did he
put a trap you don't put a trap there
clever Jason it was probably John Luke
Oh suck it no I think you're gonna get
out I think you're gonna get out you're
gonna get it all dude split second son
of a [ __ ] I can't aim with this why
can't I aim cuz you dropped it when he
picks you up you drop it [ __ ]
there it is right there oh he's walking
away
great dumbass what is he teasing me
all right probably find a health pack or
a health spread
do I know you regen you don't regen
you're gonna be walking like this for a
very long time that's really dumb I was
walking yeah you can spread it
this place looks like it's been tapped
out yeah I think so all right mmm I feel
like I it's like less D saturated right
I don't know if like was I'm just really
hoping I don't have to look like this
little time oh look who's in here
according to GameSpot apparently Jason
Voorhees is also in the chat right now
what what that's gamespot yeah I have
keys
I think cars ready come with me holy
[ __ ] really gotta go I'm injured hold on
hold on wait I'm a little injured but
okay I'm going with you go that's
awesome for me to get you do you have
help a first aid oh my god I'll drop
your legit how do I drop it no idea
screw it let's go let's go let's do it I
didn't do as cool as you that's fine
it's cuz you're injured yeah it's cuz
I'm injured you're really fast nope
that was funny fufu do not bunny foo-foo
do not leave me you're really fast do
not do not leave me oh [ __ ] sunny stop
go go go go
oh no don't shoot ya robbed
[Music]
no you're good oh yeah Oh where's the
exit take a right take a right
Sam take a right [ __ ] try to Steve you
can turn to your left left is the main
road there you go go straight there
straight that way staying ready oh this
way yeah hey keep oh this way yeah yeah
[Music]
that was good there's a good one man huh
[Music]
just like the movie huh just like it I
thought it was Scott free Scott free
home free
ah dang it
Sam I didn't see him ever do that it's
like slam that [ __ ] I mean you're spooky
still still still smoking you got this
fix the car spooky Oh your body man I
need I'm upset but I guess it is what it
is I didn't know where to go [ __ ] I was
so panicked I like my heart was racing
[ __ ] it was hard to drive to be honest
that guy it's crap buddy foo-foo [ __ ]
screaming alright when I saw Jason - I
knew we're done I knew he could do
something I should have hit reverse you
gotta dang it damn it
did you swoop in and take it
straight straight panic I mean we might
as well see how this pans out yeah damn
it
that guy was so funny do it and that's
crazy it's like he can warp right he can
teleport I'm like catch up with you the
whole time like you are not done when
you're in that car oh man how it's so
amazing what that was Joey right Joey
was uh yeah I wanted to captured that I
would like to see his his replay yeah we
got a cake yeah whatever I mean we got
the screen that's fine honestly I think
it's funnier with with your reaction
yeah yeah the other thing too is I was
truck the other thing was is like t is
to hold and talk so I'll try to talk to
him but I couldn't turn right so it's
like hard to communicate and talk to him
dr. gonzo asks is that Tommy Jarvis
this isn't Tommy Jarvis but we probably
just that yes I said yes is Tommy Jarvis
so he's like so if someone interacts
with the radio then the first person who
dies I think its first but you guys they
come back as Tommy Jarvis with a shotgun
with a single brown that all seen
honestly whenever it gets to the car in
the car
God just coming across like guys ik dude
I got the keys and everything it's like
oh [ __ ] it's on you know everything
don't tell any of the other what
happened oh is this your oh that's all
that's me this is me right here oh did
someone get in the car oh no it's not uh
HF gaming asses your first time playing
no we played quite a bit last night
actually okay like a few hours last
night but the other guy we were with who
was with us in the car that was his
first time playing he said I think or
was that someone else that was someone
else okay
there's not [ __ ] Beck hi
the guy honey booboo knew exactly what
what's up he you could hear it his voice
he knew like someone says that bunny
scream he was watching Oh Eric Eric says
he's watching another guy stream of it
[ __ ] visuals like going the wrong way
turning around and then just the
silhouette of Jason in the middle of the
road just like in any other game you
would think it's reasonable to nail
someone with a car but of course like
I'm in my head I was like this is not
right you know it's like this is not
gonna work because the game has
incorporated you know it I've seen it
but are you just back your head you know
that contacts gonna go sour oh [ __ ] I
was funny well this is boring you get to
the car repair the car and get the F out
of there so yeah I mean that's why you
started so that's why you would have
what a someone who had high high repair
stats right how boring this is they're
both of Ranas stamina oh this is your
next he's still alive though
Brian and the chat says Jason is creepy
good point I smell like [ __ ]
reminds me of kylo Ren right there
breeze like super English breeze sick
kiss yeah I will finish what you started
nothing will stand in our way
you can't learn get hold your face like
that
you can't we shared God what happened
oh hell yeah this is it
Oh Oh smart move oh damn this camera
work is fun I think Joe he's got um yep
damn our IP who's next
left Nick and is it silky Oh crashing oh
damn
Oh deja vu right here hey yeah I guess
you could repair it or something
hey bunny foo-foo can you hear me yeah
dude that was extremely funny I'm sorry
I screwed up that driving though that
was amazing right one Pony would worry
about it it was great that was great
right when we saw him in the middle road
I and any other game Oh Dale in any
other game you could probably hit him
right and kill him but I was like nah
this is not gonna plaintiff hangout at
all I thought oh my god that was so
intense it's just Nick lesson now I can
type a car
run for the car Nick run for the car
listen there's something with like being
in water he could like see you easier or
something oh I think you can drown well
I don't know anything yeah oh he can
swim faster than you two in water so if
you try to swim away he'll catch up to
super either oh yeah
oh damn 30 seconds left
30 seconds left oh I hope he wins too
spooky Nick Nick Nick Nick Nick Jason
Vorhees there is he says you don't know
anything about Friday well that was a
good one to end on it really doesn't get
much better than that I mean it could
but we don't have the time that's gonna
do it
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with us playing this game if you uh if
you had a good time and liked what you
saw feel free to subscribe and hit that
like button so we can do more stuff like
this yeah and make sure to come back
every day at 11:00 tomorrow you have a
stream to write that's right tomorrow we
have a Peter and myself for doing
another Dino DNA stream where we play a
no dinosaur game it's pretty
straightforward however I think tomorrow
is going to be Tarak - we're going to
play that morning and then later in the
day we'll be playing vanquish oh yeah
cool yeah that just recently came out on
PC but yeah thank you guys so much for
watching yeah
you get anything else you're working on
you don't like an easter egg video for
this right the 11th Easter Egg the video
on this probably a weekend maybe early
next week
cool just like comparing this to the
movies instead I'm looking forward to
that myself actually
we all will see it's got it yeah that's
about it thank you guys so much have a
great rest of the week and yeah take
care see ya
[Music]